اوهم الجميع بان ابنته الشابه هجرت
عائلتها لانها لم تعد تطيق العيش معهم
اربعه وعشرون عاما اعتقدت خلالها الام بان
ابنتها تعيش في مدينه اخرى لكن الحقيقه
المرعبه كانت ان الفتاه لم تبرح منزل
العائله طوال كل تلك السنوات حيث كان
والدها يحتجزها في القبو دون ان يعلم بها
احد
الاسم جوزيف فريتزل التهمه الاحتجاز
القصري والاغتصاب المكان النمسا
الحكم السجن مدى الحياه
في الثامن والعشرين من ابريل عام 2008
استيقظت النمسا على انباء ابشع جريمه في
تاريخها الجاني فيها كان مهندس الكهرباء
المتقاعد جوزيف فريد صاحب 73 عاما والضحيه
ابنته اليزابيث القصه بدات في هذا المنزل
الواقع في مدينه النمساويه عائله تعيش
حياه عاديه الى ان بلغت الابنه اليزابيث
سنه 18 حينها خشي الاب جوزيف من مغادرتها
للمنزل لتستقل بحياتها فعد مخططا اجراميا
لا يخطر على بالي بشر جهز الاب حجره سريه
بلا نوافذ في قبو المنزل وسودها بباب من
الاسمنت المسلح وقفل الكتروني ثم استدرج
ابنته الى هناك بحجه مساعدته في نقل بعض
الاغراض واغلق الباب خلفه تارك نبنته
حبيسه ذلك المكان الموحش
لم تتجاوز مساحه الحجره الستين مترا وكانت
مقسمه لثلاث غرف صغيره وحمام ومطبخ ومجهزه
ببعض قطع الاثاث وجهاز التلفاز وبسبب
الجدران السميكه وعدم وجود نوافذ لم تسعف
صرخات الاستغاثه لابنه المسكينه في وصول
صوتها الى احد ولا حتى الى امها التي كانت
تسكن مع والدها في الطابق العلوي وتعتقد
ان ابنتها هجرت العائله وقررت العيشه في
مدينه اخرى الابشع من كل ذلك كان مداومه
الاب على اغتصاب ابنته طوال كل تلك
السنوات حتى انجبت منه سبعه اطفال الاول
توفي بعد ولادته بساعات بعد تقاعس الاب عن
علاجه اما الباقون فاخرج جوزيف منهم ثلاثه
اطفال كان يضعهم وهم رضع امام باب المنزل
ويرفق معهم رسائل لاهام زوجته او جدتهم
بان اليزابيث انجبتهم وارسلتهم اليهم
ليعيشوا مع العائله فيما بقي ثلاثه ابناء
اخرين محبوسين في القبو مع امهم 24 عاما
لم تبصر فيها اليزابيث التي اصبح عمرها 42
عاما ومعها ابنائها الثلاثه ضوء الشمس الى
ان جاء يوم مرضت فيه ابنتها مرضا شديدا
واوشكت على الموت مضطر الابى لنقلها الى
المستشفى وهنا جاءت اللحظه التي كشف فيها
كل شيء
[موسيقى]
ايرلانيه
شكلها كشف ملابسات الجريمه صدمه لدى
الجميع في النمسا لكن الصدمه الكبرى كانت
من نصيبي والدتي اليزابيث التي دخلت في
حاله نفسيه صعبه بعد ان علمت ان ابنتها
كانت تعيش كل تلك المده على بعد طابق تحت
اقدامها وهي لا تعلم
القي القبض على الاب الذي اعترف بكل شيء
خصوصا بعد مواجهته مع ابنته وابنائها في
قاعه المحكمه وحكم عليه عام 2009 بالسجن
مدى الحياه لكن ربما جميع عقوبات الارض لا
تعادل يوما واحدا قضته اليزابيث في جحيم
قبوي والدها المرعب